[Music]
hundreds gather at a funeral March for
the six Palestinians killed in an
Israeli raid that lasted several hours
Israel says one of them was wanted for
killing two Israelis from an illegal
settlement near hawara over a week ago
Israeli troops used shoulder-fired
missiles to destroy a house where they
say the 49 year old suspect had
barricaded himself in
it
as you can see even if they demolish all
our houses our spirits will remain high
we hope the injured recover and peace be
upon those who died
dozens of Palestinians were wounded
during the raid but ambulances weren't
able to reach many of those in critical
condition while the injured Palestinians
remained unattended helicopters were
used to evacuate soldiers hurt during
the confrontations
our brave Chiefs operated surgically in
the hearts of the murderous Den as I say
again and again whoever hurts us his
blood is on his hands
Palestinian officials say this latest
raid amounts to Israeli declaration of
war against the Palestinians we have to
see the link between the difficulties
the Israeli government is facing inside
Israel and their need to further
escalate in their attacks against
Palestinians in order to please the
constituency in Israel of this
right-wing government the International
Community has been calling for a
de-escalation for weeks but the reality
on the ground is far from it human
rights organizations say the stepped-up
Israeli raids demolitions and settlement
expansion in the occupied West Bank
amounts to Collective punishment
Palestinians
as the number of Palestinian deaths this
year alone continue to rise
the Janine refugee camp has been a hot
spot for armed Palestinian resistance
against the Israeli occupation nearly
half of those killed in occupied West
Bank this year are from Janine and
scenes like this aren't expected to go
away anytime soon
in the occupied West Bank